لمواجهه موجات الغلاء المتلاحقه بدات ام
سحر في الاعتماد على نفسها في عمل
المخبوزات عوضا عن شرائها وبدات تبيع
الجيرانها واهل المنطقه
قبليها باعمل الحاجه دي اوزعها واطلع
الشغل الدنيا غاليه
الدقيق بعد ما كان ب 13 وصل 20 وفي ناس
بتبيعه ب 22 فعل هما الاول كنت باجيب بال
50 كيلو فمع غلو الحياه بقيت اجيب 25 بس
لما الغلاء كده في بيتنا احسن منه حاجه
نظيفه ومن حاجه بناكلها برده وبنبع منها
الشرح كله كان بيجيء ياخذ منه لما الحاجه
غليت صراحه يعني ما فيش احد بيجي بكثر هذا
لم يكن تفكيره وسحر وحدها فقد انتشرت نفسه
الفكره لدى عدد من السيدات اللاتي اصبح
شغلهن الشاغل البحث عن السلع الارخص ثمن
واتباعه اساليب اقتصاديه في الطهور وتقليل
الكميات وتوفيرا نفقات بدلا من شراء
الاطعمه الجاهزه على سبيل المثال
بالضبط دلوقت يعني ما ينفعش ان انا ار
اصلا لا انا ما عادش فيه فايد عشان نرمي
وفي حاجات من النت برده بشوف الحاجات
الحديثه بقى اللي همم اللي بتتعمل وباحاول
اجربها وبحاول اجرب البيتزا المخبوزات
يعني حاجات المخبوزات اللي في الافران
باحاول اعملها انا بابقى اقل الامكانيات
تقام الان معارض دول للسلع الغذائيه في
جميع المحافظات المصريه لبيع السلعه
بالتنسيق مع الشركات والغرف التجاريه باقل
من اثمانها في الاسواق او في الوقت نفسه
كثفت اجهزه الدوله من الرقابه على الاسواق
وطرحت كميات الممثله التي تباعه على
بطاقات التموين باسعار ثابته منذ فتره
طويله وهو ما يرحب به التجار لان انت
دلوقت لما يكون عندك السكر مع 10 جنيه
ونصف وساب سعر سعره وبيكافل 65 مليون
مواطن
فالسعر الحر همم لو علي شويه ما بقاش في
تكالب عليه يعني فالتوازن ده اهم حاجه
الحكومه عاملاه التوازن واهم حاجه السلعه
موجوده بينزل من الوزاره
وتفتيش بينزل من الشركه الشركات التابعه
نفسها علشان ضبط اي مخالفات او تجاولات
بتحصل في موضوع السفر ارتفاع الاسعار يؤثر
على جميع الفئات بشكل او باخر وبينما ياخذ
الامر شكلا ساخرا على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تزداد مشاهدات الفيديوهات
الخاصه باعداد الاكلات بطريقه اقتصاديه
بينما تدعو ام سحر الا يتجه جميع زبائنها
للخبز في المنازل حتى تجد من تبيع له هذا
الخبز الشهي تامر نصره العربيه القاهره